hey what's up Samuel lead I'm standing
in gold Smith Street in Birmingham and
I've just recently set up a new company
and it's a lending company and I set
that up to help my students and my
friends who wanna buy properties using
none of their own money and I'm now
financing their deals now ten years ago
I was often buying properties using
other people's money
even now I'm sometimes buy properties
using none of my own money but sometimes
depending on the deal I like to finance
the property and get a guaranteed return
suck in this street very good friend of
mine who's a very very good property
investor has just secured that property
for a hundred and fifty thousand pounds
he's about to spend 120 on it
217 total and then the new value is
expected to be around 350 to 400
thousand pounds cracking little deal
I've put in all the money he's put in no
money and I'm gonna get a guaranteed
return on investment of 14% I've got a
first charge on the property and I'm
gonna be completely hands-off and get a
fixed return on investment I know the
guy who I've let the money has got a
good choice in houses he's also good a
good choice in cars because this is mine
and this is his so what I welcome sad
coming up man hey you got the money just
this morning I have indeed excellent for
you so this is the house why how did you
find there oh it's through another
friend of mine it's like let tell
everybody what I do in terms always
looking for good deals and he called me
and said I've got this amazing deal
that's come up would you like to have a
look at it I literally came to see it
cuz I don't live very far from this I
know the area very well and I've got
three properties just on that street
over there
you're like a property is they really
interested think you didn't find the
house someone found it yes you didn't
fund the house no I funded it but you're
going to be making most the money yeah
and I won't be doing the work these
hands have not seen hard work affect me
I are responsible for delivering the
outcome that's why I see my goal as but
it's really a case making money for
everybody involved so why don't you just
explain why this is a really good deal
for you why it's a good deal for me I
guess it's a great deal because first of
all it's on the street where the ceiling
price is very high there's some
properties on this street that I've
achieved some really high pricing in
recent times so that means there's a
real big buffer for us to be able to
increase the price on be able to create
a profit on it so
that's that's the key thing first of all
and also with these it's a nice little
flip deal in the sense that because it's
a it's a very desirable area they're not
difficult to sell round here so you're
gonna but you go dude up and sell it
yeah effective it's a Buy I'm gonna get
more money whatever happens absolutely
because I've got a charge on the
property we've got an agreement which
was drawn up by a solicitor
how was it working with me so far
absolutely fantastic
you know we've knowledged a few years
and I've been doing this about 13 years
building what I've really built my
business using other people's money and
that's abstract it's worked well for me
it means I can do lots of deals at the
same time yeah and as we've known each
other for for a little while it's a nice
sweet deal for you as well and it means
that actually I can push up the price
and which I possibly can and i still get
i can make you more money out of it your
returns fixed why would I give you my
money and get 14% when all I could find
a property myself that would give me 20
or 25 percent well I guess some of its
leverage it's a case of there's only so
many hours in the day there's so many
yeah I can do and we aren't doing I'm
leveraging my time here absolute because
the thing is I've got my own projects
going on people people say to me people
are know people are gonna say why would
you put your own money in and get 14%
when you could invest it yourself and
get more but then if I invest it might
if I invest in myself I'm gonna have to
do the work I don't have to be
responsible I'll borrow other people's
money sometimes then people said why
would you borrow someone else's money
and not put your own money in truth is
I'm open to everything as long as I'm
making money and that's what it's
ultimately about it's about creating
something that works for everybody yeah
and we can always make more money but we
can't make more time yeah how much money
we make we can't make much and the
reason I got I got a special deal was
sad and I said look I want to get 14%
because really normally I'd want a bit
more than that it's only short-term
you're probably gonna pay back in six
months yeah six nine months six nine
months out of the deal yeah so the
reason I've given him such a low write
form it for you is a high rate because
you like to you like to get you like to
only pay 10% I like to get 18% so we
compromise on the basis that Thad would
document everything for my YouTube show
would would so that you guys as YouTube
audience can learn the process you can
learn about money lending you can learn
about finding deals you can learn about
refurbs so such on the handover to you
and you've got the keys anyway because
you bought the house I look forward to
receiving my passive income and I look
forward to my YouTube guys learn
a lot from you absolutely thanks so much
take them around I'll see you around all
right thank you so we're just outside
the house now as you can see he's in a
little bit of a sorry state these towels
and a little bit dated right now but the
street is an amazing Street what it
means is on this street the prices are
quite high we've got a really good deal
on this property it means there's enough
of a buffer for us to create an amazing
finish and nice luxury has that's
intention that's what we want to do with
this house as you'll see inside in a
moment the last person that lived here
has not really kept it in the best state
so come on through why don't we why
don't we have a look inside if you come
on through let's have a look at the
first reception room so here's the first
reception room and we have a beautiful
fireplace here which actually will all
get replaced really what we're doing
this property stripping everything back
to brick and just really modernizes you
can see it's not been touched for quite
a long time it's in quite a state the
property the carpets are really nice for
gonna have to change them one thing you
can't see on camera
is the smell and it is a little bit of a
stench but as I said to Samuel when we
met here and I said Samuel can't you
smell the money and that's exactly what
he's about with this particular property
so come on sir let's have a look at the
next reception room this room has had
some change of the years these houses
were built in Victorian time probably
about 1910 1930s that sort of range in
terms of when it was initially built
again this kind of fireplace is all get
stripped back just to make the rooms a
little bit more spacious the staircase
the reason we were thinking of moving
we're going to keep here for the moment
so in the reception rooms there won't be
a huge amount of change what really
sells houses its kitchens bathrooms and
the space and the layout of the space
when this house was built about a
hundred years ago it was designed for a
completely from lifestyle what we want
to do now is make it more modern make it
make it work for a Niner sorry or 2019
family maybe a four four-bedroom house
absolutely the intention with this so
come on through it's got a little
basement here which we're not likely to
use just maybe a little bit storage
space the kitchen is quite dated
as you can see really as as the whole
houses but it's got a lovely little
extension on the back so what we intend
to do is to take this much further back
to make it much bigger make it a nice
beautiful modern open-plan kitchen with
diner
nice double doors out into the garden
such a lovely view there may be dying
table again here we've got this bathroom
which will all get demolished here I
don't think the blue Suites work anymore
and this part of the building is a new
extension as I said new that's been
probably number of years ago but our
plan is to really push this out much
further into the back garden so we can
have the beautiful double doors open at
the back into the garden
this will probably pop a kitchen and
further baffle some beads on the dining
space so we've got two plans with this
with this building we've got planning
application has just gone in to convert
it to a four bedroom house and also to
convert the loft space as well as well
as this extension space but then we've
also got an application just in the
permitted development as well which
means that we don't have to wait for
planning so just in case we have a
little bit of knock back on planning
we're not expecting to but just in case
we've got a plan B solve that we can
just crack straight on and get this get
this work done
so let's go on upstairs now and have a
look what we've got upstairs in this
property swims here so like the cobwebs
this one is the front reception room
which is the largest room in the house
so again with this particular room not a
huge amount of work that we've done here
just kind of stripped back replastered
modernize and overall the popular fully
refurbished the rewired replumb new
windows new skirting doors frames
everything will pretty much be brand new
so we like an amazing new house because
this room big enough will have an
ensuite room in here as well that's the
plan with this room let's go on through
and have a look at the second room so
this is the the second bedroom I the
middle bedroom originally this would
have been built as a two bedroom house
we do have three bedrooms because
they'll have moved the original bathroom
that was downstairs that lovely blue
suite that we were looking at so this
would have been the second bedroom again
this one will stay pretty much as it is
all this will come out this really dated
style
furniture just to kind of make it much
more modern and much more appealing
let's go on have a look through the the
last bedroom the small bedroom this room
as you can see it needs a little bit
more work doing to it this is this
really just years and years of neglect
and I guess I have to bind lots and lots
of houses you get a sense for what
you're looking for and an idea of how
serious something is so I had a look at
this initiative and I came to see and
you know I had a feeling that actually
it's not something too serious we can we
can deal with it we can get it repaired
but then also made sure my very
experienced builder came and had a look
as well after me just in case I missed
anything and he's quite happy with the
way this this property is this has
really been as I said neglect the
gutters have been unkept for many years
and you've had water slowly seeping
through and after years and years this
is this is what's happened over here
originally this would have been built as
the as the bathroom this so it would
have been a two bedroom house this would
have been a bathroom at some point of
the years it's been changed to a bedroom
and the bathroom has got moved
downstairs in that little extension we
went to we went to see just short while
ago
it's our plan here is to try and push
this room back over the extension to
make it a much bigger room so we can
create a bathroom here as well as a
bedroom behind it so we'll end up with
three rooms on this first floor as well
as a bathroom and we'll have an ensuite
in the main bedroom we talked about so
that's a plans here so you might be
thinking where's the fourth bedroom well
let me show you how we're going to
create that so we come back this way
we're back in the the front from bedroom
and the way the staircase is designed
we've got a cupboard just here and which
really is just a waste of space there
effectively what we will do here is
bring the staircase background and it
will just go straight back up into the
loft here so it will follow the existing
staircase off I mean the loft spaces
where we'll create the fourth room and
again depending on whether we get the
planning permission root will we use
permitted development will depend on the
size of the loft
but again the loft either way we'll have
it on ensuite as well so we'll have an
ensuite in this room ensuite in the loft
master bathroom here three bedrooms here
one bedroom on tops off
so again that's what's going to allow us
to really push up the value of this
particular property and because the
ceiling prices are high we can do as
much as we can to make a really quality
finish and a nice desirable family has
for twenty nineteen living so let's go
out into the into the back of the house
now so here some bad little bit of work
over the years these windows have been
changes doors being changed this was
probably originally where the initial
door was to come out when it was built
many many years ago and over time
they've also built this extension this
is the bathroom that we went to look at
from the inside that beautiful blue
bathroom suite and the the lot of the
work that will be done on this property
will pretty much be in this space this
is where we want to bring it out as it
was already a little bit of a jungle
I've actually chopped it all down just
to try and get a sense of space out how
much space we have on what we might be
dealing with in the garden before we
start work so this is already being
cleared out the plan will be to bring
that extension out here we'll probably
be kind of around this sort of space so
it would be much more bigger the kitchen
diner will come out to here and if we
get the planning to extend the the room
above that will come out of the
extension as well so so the lot of the
work will be done here outside inside
we're really back just kind of making it
have that that exquisite modern feeling
that's really what we're focusing on so
I'm expecting this project to take about
four months in terms of all the work the
building team will literally start
working here within days they'll be here
starting to work starting to strip out
whilst the planning applications going
through a while so we're still waiting
for some of that to come through as well
so one of the things Samuel I agreed to
do with this deal is to document it to
help you with this journey so we'll be
back filming different stages of it to
help you see the progress and see the
changes because sometimes is difficult
to explain how something will look and
when you see the finished article or
help in terms of seeing the different
stages there just to give you a quick
overview the numbers again on this
particular property so we purchased at
150 thousand pounds I've found it
through another source of contact a man
who bought it to me it's in South
Birmingham a wonderful area I don't live
too far from here and I know the area
really well I have other properties
nearby this street as well and knowing
what the numbers are what we can achieve
and really star uplift I'm really
interested in what we can create and
that's what means that the the profit is
guaranteed in this particular deal so
we'll probably have about 120
pants Bend there's quite a significant
reverb needs to be done as well as the
extension that we're doing under on the
property as well so we've got planning
application in and also permitted
developments are two potential routes
that we're looking to follow as long as
we don't have no issues with planning
will go straight without otherwise we've
still got the permittee develop as a
backup a backup option there then at the
back of the property we'll have a big
dormer that will come out for the
bedroom at the top so in total in terms
of spend live 270 which is a lot Samuels
funded effectively the whole project
there's no other loan bridge or mortgage
or anything on it's just funded
privately Samuel that's really how I've
built this business of the last 30 years
by finding great deals partnering people
have got the cash and shared the profit
because we can end up with a figure of
maybe around 350,000 upwards possibly
even close to 400 as an end value I can
fix a return with Samuel you know he'd
like a great return on his money all I
try and pay as less as possible so we
kind of agreed at the 14 percent works
really well for him for the time frame
you've got the money works really well
for me as well so hopefully within about
nine months we should have turned this
round and be exited at the deal
completely it's in an area where there's
lots of sales it's very active not many
do come up for sale when they do the
sell very quickly so fairly comfortable
unconfident will sell relatively quickly
as well
Walker with a healthy profit a
win-win-win would be amazing home for
somebody to live in be a great return
for Samuel and be a great deal for me as
well in terms of profit we make on it so
the way the fundraising worked on this
particular deal is when I had this in a
number of the deals I had kind of a
message on social media that I've got a
few deals coming through on the pipeline
if you're interesting work with me
you've got some funds Sami lab known for
a little while he sent me a message and
say look you know might be interested
let's meet up and have a look Sam will
pop round to mine we met came around
with Amanda and the kids as well and
then what we did we came and look at
this particular property we went through
the numbers or talked about how it's
going to work because we known each
other while there are some understanding
there we discussed the numbers and how
it was going to work Sam will organize
the money and the money just literally
landed just this morning as we as we got
here today so we're ready to crack
straight on the way the funding and
initiative worked I had already
purchased the property so that's how it
happened so quickly and I had my money
some of my money tied up in it so Samuel
effectively come in with his cash
that will cover the purchase price and
the renovation allows me to take my cash
out and move it into another project
that's why I've been able to do so
quickly for the timing-wise being
brilliant money landed just as samples
turned up today as well to have a look
around the project well I'm really
excited about the project and I think
that we've got a great investor here
taking care of everything
I just love restoring houses and seeing
them restored I think that money is
people think that to make money you have
to be greedy but actually you know what
money is the certificate of thanks sad
is going to be helping the end buyers of
this by giving them a property it looks
great
we're helping the economy and we're
helping the housing market by finding
houses that are sober and down and
restoring them I'm helping sad by giving
him the money he's helping me by giving
me interest like the more value you can
add the more people you can help money
follows I really believe that so really
excited to see the progress and I'm glad
that I have to be involved because to be
honest I'll enjoy just relaxing this
summer I think yeah absolutely yeah it's
about helping so many different people
be the builders it'll be the architects
you know the planning team there's so
many people benefit from a project like
this and a problem in which you gotta
let money flow through you rather than
trying to hold on to end this is a
really good example of us as sides
thanks so much thank you so much good
business so I hope you enjoyed that not
only are we going to be documenting this
journey and you'll get to see the stages
of how it progresses but also my plan is
to document lots of other journeys of
people of students of colleagues so if
let me know what kind of projects you
want to see whether it's rent to rent
whether it's refurbishes whether it's
build negotiating bangla deal in the
first place let me know what you want to
see comment below and I'll make it
happen don't forget to subscribe and
share the video if you enjoyed it thank
you I'll see you next time
[Music]